you sat down what's got eastwood yeah
he's a member of the fascinate franchise
and what was going on between Dewayne
Johnson and Vin Diesel What did he say
well you know what I was glad that I got
to talk to Scott he's a newbie to the
franchise right and we haven't really
got to hear what really happened well
Scott told me his version were you
surprised
after the fact now when you're seeing
kind of Ben and Dwayne may become at
odds I had a great time working on the
film yeah I don't know about that stuff
we have barbecues like every day on set
like Tyrese would put on barbecues for
everybody
we'd go run out and shoot a scene come
back and listen to music and you know
eat grilled chicken we're gonna ship
here so that's all business in his new
movie Snowden playing Joseph
gordon-levitt CIA boss and while Scott
is the son of Hollywood legend Clint
Joseph maybe starting his own dynasty
with the birth last August of his and
wife Tasha son Edward snowed who has
asked the question what was the most
important day in his life
what's yours I'm a new dad and and and
frankly Etta I don't really love talking
about my kids so much and in the press
but obviously I mean this is birthday
can you tell me anything in that in
Snowden that's shailene woodley made
famous in the divergent series but now
comes the news that the next installment
of divergent is coming out next year as
a television movie how do you feel about
that it's the news it's the word on the
street I didn't sign up to do a
television show so I'm not sure that I
will be a part of that television show
but out of respect to the studio and to
everyone involved I don't think it's
been finalized that that's what they're
doing well actually it is a done deal
and not only is it gonna be a TV movie
but the studio announced they're gonna
spin it off into a TV series